professor we already know what
Christopher Steele's gonna say because
he said it in an interrogatory under the
threat of perjury I have no idea if any
of this dossier is true Hillary paid for
it and yeah I hated Donald Trump because
he told everybody but they still used it
as the bulk of information to get that
FISA warrant against not only Carter
page but a backdoor into all things
Trump campaign transition and presidency
well I'm glad he's testifying or at
least appearing in front of the Justice
Department I think the questions they'll
put to him in order to try to protect
the investigation will be based on
chronology you know when did you realize
that the report wasn't as valid and
solid as you originally thought it was
when did you learn that it was paid for
by Democrats and that wasn't disclosed
because what he said up to now is the
report itself is not valid but what we
need to know is when they knew it and
what they did about it and did anybody
misrepresent what they knew at any
particular processor it was a or
fester it is an unverifiable document
because it's authors says he can't stand
by it and in October 20 well first Bruce
or warned everyone in August of 2016 we
know two weeks before Comey signed that
first FISA application he was warned
again and there were other warnings and
he still put a signature on a spying
document he deny spying on not only
Carter page but in an opposition party
look low intelligence yeah
raw intelligence like that should never
be the basis for a FISA warrant that
intrudes on the rights of American
citizens privacy we need to have more
than that and we need to have complete
candor from anybody who signs the FISA
warrant they have to tell the court look
we have this we're not sure how valid it
is the author is not they never tell the
court Hillary I paid for it I know well
it's it's there's something in a
footnote but they clearly intended to
mislead the court into the making
they had a credible source that was
enough to justify intruding on the
privacy of an American citizen every
civil libertarian or too much concerned
about this process